so today we are hanging out with Ellen
Kim I've never actually met her but I
heard a lot of boaters than Danielle and
Danielle always talks about says how
much she loves her she has a great
personality but today we are going to
learn how to dance which is not which is
not one of my Forte's at all I'm Tyler
how to dance sexy today
Korean style dancing is ten times more
fierce than any other type of dance but
you've ever seen people look at a big
man like me I'm like oh he's slow he's
not flexible at all
I'm actually quite flex I'm flexible as
[ __ ] look at this with that right there
what have you ever seen somebody my size
do this huh yeah think about that yes
magnet buddy no bonus invited button na
hey but in all I say I give myself about
five minutes before I start throwing up
I grew up with a whole bunch of dancers
my whole life you know you may know some
of them as the Jabbawockeez
no but seriously I do know a couple of
them but they've they've been net and I
just watch these guys dance Maho I never
done it myself I was always intrigued
but I didn't like the fact that I went I
would sweat will get sore and get tired
and fall asleep or that it requires work
yeah music stretching is go ahead you
wish you hadn't booty bother you but
yeah actually I do
let's just grab my fat on my kneecap the
mother-daughter it's game over because
I'm going to spoil the crap out of her I
want to keep her locked up I would just
I already set somebody up don't start
with something very very sexual and then
very advanced oh yeah well you know that
oh my goose is a little bit good
I made this sexy I mean its logo okay
you have to like be more on the sensual
side
okay so there's musicality to this I'm
kind of get into her don't be about that
okay think about meeting a heifer yes
good thank good the cheese just all
opinion and yes when people dance like
you look at it and you're like okay
maybe I could do it too
because they're just following
instructions but no it's not the same
because in my head I think I look just
as good as her but it doesn't look that
way all you're gonna do is step with the
right okay if you guys definitely like
some little go together yeah step on the
coast Jack ah what the heck oh you went
to bed that's too much magnet
yeah shopping you want to like feel like
like you just tap all okay oh yeah if
anything I look like a dumbass ah [ __ ]
well one two and three and listen but at
a certain point I do believe that I
started getting a little overly
confident step into the river wrap it up
tah-tah so you ain't Kaiba yeah and then
you're going my stomach hurt my stomach
but gives us so much sexy it looks like
my stomach's dropping I'm typing it up
when we said sexy dance I thought I was
thinking sexy asn't like you know what I
mean like what you just you can't take
your like giving birth what the baby oh
yes oh my god yeah drop my wallet sir
can you get a close-up of this sweat
beans bit of time okay so mom she asked
me doing like a million squats
they're just saying that girls do when
they kick it to the tip of their vagina
and they stroke it down all the way to
their thigh and they just will let's
wait but this is way different you know
saying you put a squat bar on my back I
like ha ha good poom poom like nothing
now drop the ball what's up oh hey my
girls ever gonna touch me again after
this you should just try this on her
okay she's laying down so just badly
I'll be a teabag Tachyon you want to see
something
no go away five six seven I'm gonna go
into the river
i'ma come
Wow
man I'll tell you right now my right
thigh is a little sore oh oh
push minutes we have even moved on
we are you gonna eight count this mortar
so much more for stepper honestly is
just a second looking for change good it
looks like I'm money it looks like I
lost my tape I'm looking a little bit
like this but it looks like I lost my
sticker like what if my shirt is going
down my pants is on there what about
Twix code in one move imagine not
sweating is the question because how are
you sweating
that's because - first of all let me
tell you something about sky ohms all
right
I'm not beloved which insulates my body
so it stores in so notice I went short
at the t-shirt and I'm warm
you got a Mick flannel and you're gonna
make thigh rubber you got triple layers
and you feel like sweating this is Jesus
made one acting so you have my big ass
doing like 30 40 squats my gams are
gonna hurt
so I collapse on the [ __ ] floor like
Jesus struck me the Holy Spirit came
inside my body what you can't keep your
hand on me why don't we always better
why can't we dance with our legs
straight like this how will you put on
the floor
ah 15-second break because my legs be
like on fire
get your purpose yeah Tabata please you
look so pretty today are you so pretty
oh my god you're so pretty it's so
beautiful
there was building you had a child
because honestly you were l'homme and
prettiest girl I've ever seen in my life
hiya boys okay this is my upper body
you'll destroy everything below the
interesting thing is we were doing it
without music for the first like half
and I didn't icarly completely forgot
that we were supposed to add music okay
I forgot there's music involved
I'm tired I'm so out of shame so when
she adds music it just completely
changes it up because the speed was a
lot faster than it was without music
first of all it's the law in the song
that was a lot faster than it was in my
head the one we practice is 4,000 times
slower than that how am I supposed to do
that
you said you said actually sounds good
and I don't understand how she expected
my feathers to catch up with that [ __ ]
she just threw me into it she goes oh by
the way be with the family movie - boom
and my [ __ ] tits are flying this way
you guys want to go to entertainment
don't be a dancer it's no point dancing
is very difficult you know for all you
guys out there that don't appreciate the
art of dance it's a very difficult
difficult thing to do
Ellen is a very talented woman and the
reason why I'm saying this right now so
I could kill a lot of times with the
rest oh my god I am in like it's like
1.5 seconds ki has a whole piece already
she just came to the earth she's
surprised she doesn't know what's in
store for her oh can you do it at the
speed that you're supposed to do it not
tonight it was
my legs are tired
so what I dip that back my legs like I
give up there's this part where she just
has me like slice the air ha ha ha ha I
call it that the [ __ ] salami slice me
up that you're like swatting a fly down
here and up here
hey yeah she sure told me for you jay-z
concert oh ok so like that jay-z concert
yeah but you gotta step with that jay-z
concert left twice ah ah that's it hey
let's take the camera and I want to show
them you you dancing Vince let's see you
learn the choreo real quick let's see
how good you are I had been dance
because I didn't want to be the only one
suffering
how's he trying to kill - I assume just
because he you know he's a b-boy that he
would understand like the dance
choreography very well but but
apparently there are two different
things
b-boying and you know sexy hip hop
choreography
what and so at some point I was like you
know what [ __ ] just b-boy and show
this [ __ ] up because she had me in pain
guys guys that that's done ha ha ha Wow
oh [ __ ] that's crazy
you [ __ ] suck oh yeah yeah you know
if somebody asked me if I would ever you
know do choreographed dancing again I
mean straight up I can honestly say hell
no
whoa how was that smoke oh the walk is
slow but dude this part right here to
cook that was heck of fat that was he
was like slow and it said oh hello hello
ha ha ha that routine was very difficult
I mean I don't even know if I
technically got the routine down but I
got just enough to get by and she said
she was proud of me because I was
actually pretty good
I did really good ok that's pretty good
don't [ __ ] lie to me don't call my
feelings I've seen great dancers and
great choreography I did not have it
upper body and my lower body were not
connected to my brain I'm proud of you
thank you so much
remember kids if you have a dream out
there never pursue